okay now you have my attention the
latest trailer for wonder woman came out
and it seemed like I was one of the only
people who was not particularly enthused
by the first Wonder Woman trailer that
came out quick recap nothing about that
waylaid by fears that it was just too
close to what Batman V Superman brought
us I mean I'm not going to rehash all my
issues with Batman V Superman but what
concerned me from the word go was that
Wonder Woman was pretty much done the
bulk of its production by the time
reaction to that movie came out so even
if they wanted to rejigger it to not fit
so much into that dark gritty overdone
world of Batman V Superman it was too
late we were going to be stuck with that
and nothing about that first trailer did
anything to change my feeling that that
was what we were going to get this one
however either the film isn't that
different in there showing that better
or props to the marketing team for
putting together something that makes it
feel like the movies gonna be different
in either case the end result is I am
now true looking forward to the movie i
don't i'm not in quite honest am pumped
yet i'm just too skeptical given the
track record for DC movies right now but
I'm not looking at it with this weary
resignation that I had kind of up to
this point almost everything about this
trailer I love I'm really enjoying what
I see of gal gadot performance I love
the fact that in her action scenes the
emphasis is is on the bracelet or
deflecting bullets for protecting people
I like that the emphasis is on defensive
tactics now I fully expect she'll kick a
whole ton of ass all over the place but
I like that shift in emphasis that it's
more on protecting people being
defensive because it gives her a
different feel because she is a warrior
but she's not a kill I mean she is a
killer she will kill people but her
stances warrior is by virtue of wanting
to protect the world not wanting to just
destroy everything that threatens it I
left that they still haven't give us a
real clear look at a villain I assume
that that woman with the weird face mask
thing is a villain I'm
to Danny Huston his own when is Danny
Huston not a villain but at the same
time they're putting so little emphasis
on there just there we don't know who
they're playing and it makes it feel
like just war is the enemy and in this
case I was in World War one the Great
War but wore this thing of man's world
that is the enemy and as far as
marketing and trailer goes that's enough
I don't need to know the details of of
Ares or whatever else you might be
dealing with there was also a lot more
color than iming to the point that it
looks like some of the shots from the
previous travel had actually been
treated to up the color and they kind of
Rhys a erated the film almost there are
only like two shots that look had that
desaturated looking that's fine i'm not
saying everything has to be vibrant
color but the week we saw her outfit and
i can actually make out red and blue
there's colors it's not just all brown
or all gray or whatever this got me
really excited that the joke may ended
on the Edit candy was okay in my work
better in context in isolation it was
iffy I was but I was loving pretty much
every second of this until the logo came
up in the theme kicked in I'm sorry I
really hate that theme for Wonder Woman
it's not a horrible piece of music but
it feels so wrong it feels like what Rob
Zombie would come up with if you asked
him to make a new theme song for Jaws my
friend Ryan said it would be a perfect
theme for a new conan the barbarian
movie and I'll go with that too it
doesn't feel like Wonder Woman it's not
triumphant it's not inspiring it's his
harsh drum beating it's like it's well
it's like a call to war again it's not a
bad piece of music but as Wonder Woman's
theme as a character no I hated it when
I first heard it in Batman V Superman it
has not grown on me since then but
obviously at this point they they're
they're sticking with it so I'm gonna
have to just I guess deal with it I'm
never gonna like it I'm just not but
I'll cope so that's my thoughts on the
new Wonder Woman trailer overall big
improvement I am actually now looking
forward to the movie and I have had a
little bit of hope restored will that
hope be justified
I see the movie or will it be another
step in the back like suicide squad was
which I also let myself get hopeful for
in any case have you seen it a wonder
woman trailer what were your thoughts on
it whatever they are drop something down
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget like subscribe check me out
on Twitter at council geeks give
Elizabeth Council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned